こんにちははじめ社長です俺の生きてきた人生の中で第3位具合の高い買い物をしまし
た
タイマーの音が良くプロゲーマーさんがゲームにするときに集中されために座る椅子な
んですけどもこれもこれもこれもそうで3つだここでゲーミングジャンですめっちゃ
座り心地よくても吹くゲームというより動画編集とかパソコンを触るときとかに使うん
ですけども
座り心地はもうめっちゃ快適なんですよゲーミングじゃああーげーめちゃ結構た掛けて
これ取れ抑え45万円台するんですけども
病脳ね今もうどく恋ゲームちゃうってましたじょ調べてもらったり打ってくださった
会社の方に聞いたところ多分世界最高額でございますそのお値段なんと
300円50番選んでございます
pa
なんでやったんだ俺そんなあげるわけで子様欲しかった
決してそんななんかゲーム勝ち z わけじゃないんですけどこれは買わなきゃ誰もた
理由がない子があったんですけども
とりあえずですね見た目が超かっこいいんですよ先にどんな感じが見えますこちらはい
どん
あのん
やってる人もかっこいいんですけどそれ以上にこの見た目画面がすげーもなんか園3台
になっていて上からこのアーム見たやつが伸びてるんですよこんな格好良いゲーミング
チェーンで手がこれゲーミングチェアをそっから怪しいんですけどもこれがおそらく
世界最高今日でゲーミング地やアプデデタースローの巣というゲームじゃあ350万円
らしいです
アペア no もう買いましたでもうすぐあの届きますこれあのゲーミングチャーター
についてくるんじゃなくてデスクトップ pc
めちゃくちゃスペックでパソコンもついてきてモニター3つも付いてきます
ヘッドセットをついていますキーボードもマウスもついてくるという写真があるんです
けどもこれが丸まで意識ついて350万円ということでエピック限りなんですけども
なんか今秋正谷マップさんなきゃバーテンにレンジ
で1年だけ置いてあるんですけどもそれがも最後の1つらしいんで買う仕組んでいい
だろうと
俺がもう俺が買うしかねえだろどこで買わせていただきました本ラスト1台ですよ
濡れなかったでしょうか売れたか売れてないのかわかんないんですけど生産中止して
ほんと鳴門市らしいのでお値段ももうマン兄に負けて負けて負けていただいで
200万円ぐらいまで安くしてもらってキュッといたしました
スレってないのでしょうかそれだってゲーミング前に350万です1を
おらんと思うんですよねなんか考えちょっと結構買われる方いらっしゃるともですけど
も山田日本のゲームに対する考え方の海外のゲームにさせる考え方また微妙に違う
でしょうね日本エコまだちょっとゲームで遊びみたいな感じられるですけど海への一部
からもゲームで言えばプロみたいですよと思うんでそれぞれ内間かけるのも普通なのか
も知れませんよっており汗が出てくる
矢東総合
待ちましょうね
家族ちょっ
大事やなぁ
組み立てに6人お店の方が来てくれますかね結構難しいらしくてちょっと自分に壁紙
縦型になるのでちょっとし自分をかけ出せない雰囲気で
が見守らせていただきますねうわぁすげぇ
ません
はすごい
ん
の設置は a ざー何のもプロフェッショナル集団の方にしていただいてもらっており
ますそれをの差などどれぐらいあるんですかね
goo
ああああああ
[音楽]
tan
re
ああああああ
ています
1時間半が経過しついに350万円のゲーミング地やが完成したのであった
でもこれ
ゲーミングチャーというよりどっちかというとロボットのコックピットではないだろう
か
テクニカルサポートのエイサーの
社員さんたちは静かに私の家を去っていったのであった
ありがとう偉い人ありがとうテクニカルサポートをありがとう
一番頑張ってなんか細かい作業してた人たち彼らは
手をあげ
静かに私の家を
あっていったのであった
暑い中本当にご苦労様でした
ありがとう
ばいばーい
[音楽]
よく完成しました350万円の原因愚痴らです
me
[音楽]
これゲーミング地やかな芸人口だからそれちょっといろいろ見ていきましょうかまず
ロゴナ
かっこいいねこれ5ペダルとかあるんですけどを受けられですねー
[音楽]
うっはっはー
0震源出せるように来シックで上がるらしいですよこれ見てし動けないも飲み物
フォルダーとかあるんですよねこれが画面側ですね
3画面風に使いますでこの上の輪っかマジでなんなんだろうって感じこれ本当になん
かかっけーよねここもついたり消したりできますこれじゃない色変わります後ろから
見るとこんな感じになっております
なにこれにゃうやばいやばいよ
pc もすっげーいいやつヘッドホンともしっかりつけさせていただいておりますそれ
はさっそく乗ってみようと思います
まずね皆さんに見せたいのはどの瞬間ですねと
後日なぁ
[音楽]
まずしっかりと開くわけですねそこでプレイヤーこうやって座って zune 日が
出来ましたと落ちるから
[音楽]
[拍手]
ローンさっき見せなく受けられるホテルはこれだって9 c コースと眠いねぇねぇ
味噌日になろうできるものもあるんですようわぁ凄い凄いわー
これでケアができるわけでバーっという実際にゲームやってみましょうもうねこれは
おもろすぎる走っで女神ん
ん yeah いいよいいねそれ
25枚そして usb 3.04つ付けれます超便利って後ろに秘密のスイッチがって
これ使うとゲームの音に反応して5が密着し触れるようなんですよ超臨場感あるゲーム
体験ができますはい2いかがでしょうか世界最高型のゲーミングちやーもう意味が
分かった
がめちゃくちゃ座った瞬間ゲームやってまず出るんですよこれでいい環境が無いわけ
やん
んじゃあね超た口当たりとかこの芸人グッズやつ予定
ってゆう丸バエどうわー
ana
[音楽]
しています
うぉっしゃーなも見れ club wire
[音楽]
blr ソーマ